Matthew Stafford the Lions quarterback
set to join us here
Matthew with this Air France he's all
set all right let's see they got
dolphins coming up
they had a win over the Packers he threw
for a couple of touchdowns there and the
Lions quarterback joins us you know let
me start with Drew Brees what did you
make of Drew Brees on Monday night the
all-time passing record um it's a pretty
incredible accomplishment obviously you
have to play an extremely high level for
a very very long time and see him do it
the way he's done that the right way for
so long is really impressive
I'm happy for him always enjoy playing
against them and and he set a new bar
out there you know a new bar for
quarterbacks to go try and get did you
watch him when you were in high school
since you're both from Texas yeah you
know obviously everybody's ever been
been a prolific passer and a winner so
you know following his career and
obviously love playing against them one
of those moments when I was you know
young in my career my first career start
was over against him so kind of one of
those no pinch yourself moments and get
to play again together just growing up
watching and playing yeah so it's pretty
cool have you done the math on your
passing yards of how old you would be
when you retire I have not that as much
as I can but I hear people talking to me
about it sometimes but it's a long way
off like I said I mean you have to do it
for such a long period of time Drew's
going to great job of keeping himself
healthy you know and has had really good
teams around him to throw the ball
around and some great receivers so it's
it's an accomplishment something that
you know maybe someday happens for maybe
it doesn't but just really proud of him
I done math for you by the way
I got you thank you I got you around
between 38 and 39 years of age that that
I've got you around that number just to
let you know just in case somebody
brings that up it does sound a little I
don't know braggadocious if you say yeah
I did the math and I'm gonna be 38 when
I break the record so I what is it
about the passing numbers now is it more
about what the offense quarterbacks are
doing or what the defense is not doing I
think the combination of both you know I
think there's some really great
quarterback play in the league right now
you know young guys the old guys I mean
it's all over the place what Pat mahomes
is doing all the way up to you know drew
and Tom still playing at a really high
level so it's it's a really good era for
quarterbacks I think in the NFL right
now and at the same time there are some
things that you know probably you know
helping offenses be a little bit more
prolific and I think it's for the better
of the game just because all of it
really is intended to keep guys safe and
keep you guys playing for as long as
they can which is ultimately what we all
want to do you know we want to play this
game as long as we can and have fun
doing it but also if you're looking at
this the way the game is now - when you
first came in how much of a difference
is it for offense and defense in your
your opinion I think it's changed quite
a bit really in all phases you know
obviously you know rules are different
for defenders now than they were back in
2009 when I came in all the Egan and
like I said earlier I think it's for the
right reasons and I think you know some
of it is tough you know it's tough to
officiate I think it's tough for certain
guys that have played for a long time to
kind of have to change the way they play
the game but I think it'll keep you guys
safe keep you guys healthy and keep it
playing longer and then offensive ly
schemes are constantly changing you know
and some of these skill players that are
coming out now are just incredible
incredible athletes big tall faster on
all of it so it's it's a really cool
time to be playing in the NFL and I
enjoy playing he's Matthew Stafford or
the Lions and they got the Dolphins
coming up on Sunday Boomer Esiason
question your leadership because you're
not fiery around your teammates what's
that mean really sure
boomer is not like I said when I first
you know about this I I haven't had to
murmur in the locker room yet so getting
that information from but you know I've
just I'm gonna be myself
and you know who I am to my teammates is
different than Who I am to everybody
else and I think that's the way it
should be I think you know we're in a
locker room for a reason we're a
football team for a reason because what
we share what we
for us and us only so that's kind of how
I feel about it but you know everybody's
got their own opinion I understand if
you win games they're gonna say good
things about you if you lose them
they'll say bad things so I get it
how are the lines how would you assess
your your group here do the first five
yeah you know I think up and down you
know we've had some really nice wins and
some losses but you know frankly we just
didn't play well and we've got to come
out and prove it every week this is the
NFL we understand that that's the way it
goes but we got to be as sensitive as we
possibly can be and that's that's how
you achieve you know long-term success
is just making sure that as a team
you're consistent you know we can a week
out have you sold
quarterback hint to the referees at
least everybody's doing everybody's I
know
defenders and let them land on me and
see what we can do but it's saying I
mean I understand the rules have changed
and you know it's you know it's tough to
be a defender out there right now I get
that you know it's you gotta you got to
change the way you play and I think it's
tough to be an official as well it's
happening so fast you know they've got
to make splits a split-second decision
but these guys come in and I don't know
where they can land I mean you saw the
Clay Matthews hits like you know one I
thought was a flag and one I didn't
think was a flag and and it does happen
in real time but I just feel for the
defensive players I don't think they
know what they can and can't do anymore
I get that and I like you said one of
them you thought was correct and one of
them you felt wasn't and that's
officiating that stuff you know I mean
this thing is happening so fast they've
got so many things to look at you know
how how long ago was the ball release
you know how much of the weight lands on
I don't know you know I mean that's
tough I think you know the rule is
intended for player safety and I
understand that and I think that's a
positive thing we just got to find the
best way to go about it and I think
it'll you know take some time but I
think it'll work itself out I had a
problem with the gray uniforms just one
let you know I said it publicly and I
want to say it too there was too much
gray in there Matthew
okay well noted I will do you have any
say over how the uniforms look oh no I
wish I did but I do not I just kind of
wear whatever's in my locker that day
and go out there and try and play it so
I'll let the guys upstairs know that you
thought that would thank you great and I
also think that you know Coach wearing
his hat backwards I mean it's got to
make up his mind it's either forward or
backwards yeah we did go back at the
pictures and I go look at Stanford he's
got it back for it no he's got it
forward but see you're a father now I
think it's a hat forward now once you
become a dad I remember people question
your leadership a quarterback that has
hat on backwards did you reach out to
your your good buddy Clayton Kershaw and
congratulate him I have not yet I need
to that's a great reminder thank you for
making me feel bad on good luck against
the Dolphins and we'll check back in
with you run you around 38 39 when
you're ready to a pass drew Brees on the
all-time good thank you buddy for more
Dan Patrick show to the audience Channel
239 on DirecTV or download the Dan
Patrick show app
[Music]